okay we finally made it we are at uh 7d
which is the very last question
uh and it was the last question because
it was a real doozy and um
people might be forgiven for looking at
this and then saying
where do i even go with this okay so
part one is meant to be a nudge into the
question then part two is the one
that really makes your head spin so
let's have a look at it together
by mathematical induction prove four
integers and greater than or equal to
two that
this string of fractions all add up to
each other
it's always going to be bigger than a
half okay
so to mathematical induction proof let's
do what we do with all mathematical
induction proofs
we'll test the base case assume it true
for some arbitrary case
k and then we'll prove it true for the
next step along k
plus 1. this part wasn't done too badly
because we're pretty good at induction
um the first thing to note is our base
case is 2 because that was provided to
us in the question
so you then say well if you put in 2
right the first term will be 1
over 2 plus 1 that's a third so just
highlight that
there is the first term and then the
second term
will be 1 over
2 plus 2 which is a quarter so you're
like okay there's the second term
but the second term is the last term
right because i've already hit
2n if n equals 2 then the final term
will be 1 over 2
times 2 which is 4. so i've already got
there this is the last term
the reason why i point this out is
because some students erroneously said
i've got a third i've got a quarter
and then i keep on going until 1 over 2n
which is
a quarter again but you already hit it
over here so there are no more
subsequent terms
this is the last term so think carefully
about where your terms
or whether rather where your series is
going to end
a third plus a quarter i've just got my
common denominator so i get 7 12
and indeed i'm trying to show that this
left hand side will be greater than half
and
seven twelfths is bigger than six
twelfths so it's bigger and a half
i'm good all right test is done now i
assume so here is the assume statement i
just take everything in the original
statement and replace
ends with k's all good to go and then
lastly
um or lastly for the the structure the
skeleton and the proof
i then have to say well what's going on
with the k plus one step now um
even before we get to the real hard work
inverted commas
even stating the k plus one step was
done pretty poorly
across the board for example a lot of
students
included one on k plus one as the first
term
the first term is often the same between
your k and your k plus one step
if you're looking back at that sigma
notation question that sigma notation
induction proof we looked at earlier in
this paper
um yeah you know you often start the
same term and then you just keep on
going a little bit further
but think about this right if you are to
substitute k
plus one into the first term of this
sequence or series rather over here you
get one over
k plus one plus one so you don't start
at one over k plus one you start at one
over k plus two
now the reason why this is problematic
is not just because you get the wrong
series
but because you're trying to prove that
this whole series is bigger than a half
well if you've got an extra term here it
makes it dramatically easier in fact it
makes it trivial
so it was very hard to you know see
satisfactory algebra
if we saw this one over k plus one term
appearing where it shouldn't okay so
that was the first issue there
shouldn't be there the second issue is
remember
this term has to go all the way up onto
1 over 2 k
plus 2 that's the final term there just
like this goes up to 1 over 2
k but what you're doing is you're
incrementing 1 along every time
k plus 1 k plus 2 k plus 3 and so on
so therefore it stands to reason that
the immediately previous term before 2k
should be 2k minus 1. that's what i
would have over here
it's just that last term minus 1 on the
denominator
so therefore over here the last term
should be oh sorry the second last term
should be
the last term minus one on the
denominator so if you had two k plus two
you should have two k plus one and a lot
of people skipped straight over to that
to
2k because they were not realizing that
the terms went up by ones
you know if i went from 2k to 2k plus 2
the terms would be going up in twos
so that was a problem some people put in
an extra term
and other people had a missing term so
that was
some common mistakes the students made i
then need to prove that that's bigger
than a half there's no change to the
right hand side in any case
so have a look at how i've done this my
desired method was to look at the left
hand side
take away the right hand side if i can
prove that if you subtract subtract half
the right hand side from both sides
you should get 0 over there so what i
want to prove is i've got a positive
number on the right hand side
or rather that the left hand side take
away the right hand side is a positive
number
again several students they began by
assuming what they were trying to prove
so they would say some version of
consider that the left-hand side
take away the right-hand side is greater
than zero but
that's what you're trying to prove that
the left-hand side minus the right-hand
side is greater than zero so if you
started here and then did a bunch of
things
you almost certainly ended up with
something that was a truism because it
was obviously true
and no actual algebraic logic had been
employed
so here's my left hand side right there
there's my right hand side
so i've subtracted it in order to make
this easier to work with you can see
what i've done
is i have added and subtracted
this same term why is that useful well
it's because it turns
this series here into something that
looks a lot more like
my assumption right i need to use the
assumption somewhere but the assumption
has this
1 over k plus 1 term that my current
series
does not so in order to include it i
can't just put it there because i want
it
if i add it i also have to subtract it
so that's why you can see me
highlighting it there
and then i can say aha if i've got let's
do it in red
if i've got all of these terms in here
they belong in they belong from the
assumption the left hand side
and i can say ah this is bigger than a
half
right in here right so therefore if i
replace it with a half
then now the original thing is bigger
i've replaced with something smaller so
now you can see
this side here with the replacement is
smaller than the original left-hand side
minus right-hand side which is
everything up here
okay so you can see that's where i've
done the substitution and please please
please
say you've done the assumption since you
say by assumption or
by the inductive hypothesis say
something to show me
that you have used the n equals k step
many students who didn't
not just made it hard for the marker to
interpret what was going on
but they used the assumption incorrectly
they had said oh i made some adjustments
to this and then did the substitution
and often did it incorrectly which was
really sad to see
okay so i've made the substitution um
and you can see i
cross over from an equation to an
inequality that was also a common
mistake that students made they
would go from an equation to an
inequality and then back and forth and
back and forth
and invariably got themselves very
confused
pick one change it when necessary
usually by an assumption
and then stay put right you want an
inequality in the end anyway you want
this inequality
that's what you're required to prove is
it easy
so once you get to the inequality
let it stay put all right that's
1 over 2 that i substituted in it can
then cancel with this minus 1 over 2
that came from the original minus right
hand side so
that's why these terms disappear i get
left with these three fractions here
and what i want to prove is that these
three fractions are going to be
they're going to be positive right
greater than z greater than 0 right
so you can see here i actually have like
terms both of these have the same
denominator 1 over
or 2 k plus 2 rather is the denominator
so when i combine them
i get uh yeah there's a plus one minus
two so you get minus one
over two k plus two that's what i get
there
but just think about this for a minute
right i've got two fractions and i'm
subtracting one from the other
if my answer to this is greater than 0
then the bigger fraction has to come
first and i should be subtracting the
smaller fraction
how can i prove that that's the case
well if you think about the fact that
you know if you subtract like what's a
bigger fraction take away a smaller
fraction
a half take away a third that's a bigger
fraction take away a smaller fraction so
therefore it's going to be positive
right
but 1 over 20 take away a third is a
smaller fraction take away a bigger
fraction so therefore
that would be negative what i've got is
a situation like the first not the
second because
look at the denominators see this
denominator here two k plus one
it's smaller than this denominator two k
plus two
a smaller denominator makes a bigger
number so therefore
this whole thing here has to be bigger
than i'm going to substitute it for
something smaller here
but this is going to be zero so
therefore
if my left hand side minus my right hand
side is bigger than this
and this in turn is bigger than that
since i've got these two fractions here
then when you collide them together and
they cancel you get zero
so now left hand side take away right
hand side is positive
that means the left hand side greater
than right hand side as required i was a
little bit messy
i keep on forgetting to say therefore by
the principle of mathematical induction
it's true
but at this point you've done all the
hard work right so i'll just conclude
like so
by the principle of mathematical
induction statement is true
okay so as i mentioned this was meant to
be a leg
up into the real question which was the
final final final part of the question
let's read it together
a series is convergent if it approaches
a finite value
when an increasing number of terms are
included
pause what's being talked about here so
introduction of language which
should be vaguely familiar but even if
you've never seen it before the example
should clarify
what what happens when you've got a
series that approaches a finite value no
matter how many terms you add on
we're pretty familiar with this if you
have a geometric progression if you have
something like say a half
plus a quarter plus an eighth and so on
that is going to converge to a certain
value no matter how many more
fractions you add onto the end here no
matter how many more terms you include
in your geometric progression this
sequence is always going to
get closer and closer and closer but
never go beyond
one this is the limiting sum right um
from a geometry progression and it's
very easy to
visualize this um and prove this for
yourself i've got a half
of this square here which has an area of
one then i've got a quarter
over here and then i've got an eighth
over here and you can see
no matter how many times i keep doing
this i get closer and closer and closer
i'm never going to exceed there's always
going to be space
to be able to say oh i can drill down
further and never get bigger than the
confines of this square
which has an area of 1. so that's why
you can see
this series converges to a value of one
geometric progressions often do this
if the common ratio is less than
or equal or rather between negative one
and one but geometric progressions are
not the only kinds of series
that converge this for example here what
is this series
it's one over one plus one over one
plus one over two plus one over six i
guess the next one will be 1 over 24
because i'm doing the factorials 1 over
120 and so on
and if you go ahead and put this into
your calculator it's a bit wild but
this converges to 2.718281828 so and so
on and so on
in other words e which is kind of cool
and awesome so there's a bit of an
easter egg
in the question so what would it mean
then
for this particular series or the series
given by
this sigma notation what would move mean
for this to converge
to a finite value well it would mean
something like
a half or sorry that's not the first
term it's one over one
then you get a half then you get a third
and then you get a quarter
and you keep on going forever it would
mean that if i kept adding terms on
i would get closer and closer and closer
to a certain value now
if you tried to put this into your
calculator because we're just you know
using our meat and flesh fingers you
wouldn't get very far before you thought
man this is slowing down this is growing
so slowly in fact it grows
logarithmically which is very very very
slow
it feels like it's going to converge to
some finite value
but it doesn't in fact to me saying that
it grows logarithmically is a bit of a
clue
if you think about the the log function
yes
true enough it grows very very slowly
but there is no point at which it stops
there's no there's no asymptote up here
the log function grows slowly but it
grows
forever and it has no limit it doesn't
converge to a finite value
and neither does this this series here
which actually has a special name it's
called the harmonic series because these
are these represent kind of like the
ratios that give you the harmonics
if you pluck a string and divide it into
ratio the harmonic series does not
converge to a finite value
so number one how do we prove that
number two
what on earth does it have to do with
this earlier part
up here
how do we see it well um i'm going to
just put one clue here
before we show you the answer and if you
haven't looked at this question before
maybe you're watching this video and you
haven't even done this exam my clue here
is that
this harmonic series that gets out of
comes out of this um
uh what's the word i'm looking for comes
out of this particular
sigma notation it includes a third plus
a quarter in it
third plus a quarter does that look
familiar from part one
if you've not attempted this question or
maybe if you got to the exam and you
um just didn't know what to do with this
part of um of the question
maybe pause the video and have a go at
it um but
if you uh would like to be spoiled or if
you've already paused the video and came
back
after um getting the answer or beating
your head against the wall
let's have a look at the solution
together here's my proof for part one
let's have a look at the proof for part
two for starters what i have written
here is
just the series that i get out of some
notation i've just
written it out in long form and you'll
see why in a second it starts with one
over one
then a half a third a quarter and so on
right
now i highlighted before that this uh
series has a third plus a quarter in it
right
now where was that familiar from well in
part one we
evaluated a third plus a quarter in
particular
we showed that it was um bigger than a
half
do you remember that um because in a
sense you can say it's bigger than a
quarter plus a quarter
a quarter plus a quarter is equal to a
half a third plus a quarter
is bigger than a half right now this is
useful to me because if it's bigger than
half then it's going to be able to be
something that i can substitute
in here because this is going to be
bigger than a half here
so i can make a statement of inequality
which is helpful right
then i also notice i've got this longer
series of fractions over here
which i haven't seen before but it
relates to the previous question again
right it fits into this exact fraction
if i were to take an
n value of 4 right let's test
this statement for n equals 4 what do i
get
the left hand side is going to be equal
to what do i start with
well it's going to be a 5th plus a 6th
plus a 7th and
i go all the way up to 2n which in this
case is 2 times 4
which is an 8. now because i've already
proven this by induction i don't even
need to do any kind of evaluation here
i can already say that that's going to
be bigger than a half
right um you know if you didn't do this
by induction you could say well it's
bigger than
you know this is an eighth here but all
of these fractions earlier they're all
bigger than an eighth right a seventh is
a big bigger than an eighth
a sixth is bigger than eight um a fifth
is bigger than an eighth so it's bigger
than
four eighths which is like i said
earlier bigger than a half right
so this string of fractions is also
bigger than a half
why is this useful to me well now you
can see if i do a substitution here if i
substitute each of these things for
a half i know that this line will be
bigger
than this line because a third plus a
quarter is bigger than a half
a fifth plus a six plus a seven plus an
eighth is bigger than a half
and you can see here this right hand
side is clearly not going to converge to
some finite value
because i've got a one plus a half plus
a half
plus a half again i can just keep adding
on halves i just need more and more
fractions
which are hard to write but they're not
hard to imagine so since this doesn't
ever slow down it's always going to have
an extra half that i can add on
the right hand side doesn't converge and
the left hand side is bigger than the
right hand side so therefore
the left left-hand side will also
converge and that is
the entire proof it is marvelously
succinct if you knew how to interpret
part one and incorporate it
but it does take a lot of thought it
takes a bit of creativity
actually which i hope is something that
you have experienced is very important
in the topic the nature of proof
a lot of other parts of mathematics
de-emphasize creativity
um but that is actually a bit of a
misconception that
creativity is not important and a
question like this or indeed a topic
like the nature of proof really
emphasizes that
so i hope these questions are helpful
and i hope they're working with the
solutions
sort of showed you insight for all the
different ways to solve these questions
make sure you have a go at trying these
yourself or
pursuing the different parts of this
exam that you knew you had trouble with
that you had a look at your exam review
where there's
really gaps in your understanding and uh
you know use these as a stepping stone
to try similar questions
that you can then now that you don't
know the solutions to those get some
benefit out of